[Music]  hey Heidi I know you're up there I know  you can hear me it's not fair  [Music]  you're taking advantage of my fear of my  my handicap how would you feel if  somebody did that to your mama I don't  know the answers to all your questions  darling I wish I did I don't know why  the landlord never takes you a rent  I don't know why the electric company  doesn't shut off your lights people fall  through the cracks in this world all the  time Heidi I guess I just figured you  and your momma fell to a luckier crack  than most and I was afraid to ask too  many questions I was afraid that if  people knew about you and your momma  they might take you away from me  I couldn't bear that  you